some new trailers coming out we got a
couple trailers to talk about one of
which being the trailer to Harry Potter
and the Deathly Hallows Part 2 trailer
one I almost can't say where we left off
just in case you haven't seen Harry
Potter and the Deathly Hallows Part 1 I
will give you a hint though this is
going to be Armageddon with Wizards
I mean the trailer starts out in the
tones really cool the music school the
voiceover is going you see Magic and
wizards and Dragons and wands and spells
you see one of those Oh help me moments
noon like the force field around
Hogwarts Goes Down that's when you know
[ __ ] is getting real I noticed a couple
scenes one in particular that's just not
in the book let's finish this the way we
started didn't happen but I'm okay with
it strangely because it just looks
really cool that is awesome that Harry
would like ever do that is why he's
badass but what's with Voldemort doing
that yell he does the same yell in
everything just in this one trailer he
doesn't like four times he's all like I
can't imitate that right there he's
falling I can't fall no try thinking
about it you're like he did that in the
Goblet of Fire too and he came back when
Harry like escaped yeah I guess it ain't
broke don't fix it I guess his yell
works for him he didn't do that yell
when he was on the back of the guy's
head though I don't think hey I don't
want to show you too much about the
trailer the trailer just looks awesome
but it's just it's a teaser trailer but
it shows you exactly what you want to
see the apocalypse with wizard robes
personally I think Harry Potter is gonna
be the biggest movie of the summer watch
is like Winnie the Pooh that'd be it
right there but if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]